TO CONVENE THE FIRST BILL
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE I ON SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AS WE
WAIT FOR QUORUM I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS PLEASE BE AWARE WE HAVE
TWO DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES TESTIMONY TODAY PUBLIC
TESTIMONY OPTIONS INCLUDE
TESTIFYING FROM THE HEARING ROOM
OR ON THE PHONE. HE'S BE ADVISED
THAT I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE HEARING ROOM OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. FOR DIAL
IN WITNESSES WE'LL ALSO BE USING
A MODERN MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON EACH BILL THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING AND YOU WILL BE PLACED
IN Q. AND TELL IT IS TIME FOR
YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTER- ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND
FLOOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS
HEARING IS PROHIBITED.
INDIVIDUALS MAY BE REMOVED IF
NECESSARY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. BUT WE HAVE TO
PROPOSE BILLS ON CONSENT
CALENDAR BUT WE WILL WAIT UNTIL
WE GET MORE MEMBERS BEFORE BRING
THAT FORWARD. WE ALSO HAVE FILE
ITEM ONE A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY
NINE BY MISTER CUNNINGHAM WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR FROM
TODAY'S HEARING- AND THIS AND
CONCLUDES MIKE HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS- ONCE. YES WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND BEGAN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- AS WE AWAIT OUR
OFFICERS AND MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO INVITE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K. HAND TO
PRESENTER BILL. YES. NINETY SIX
NINETY EIGHT POINT PROTECT. AND
WHEN YOU ARE READY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WANT TO START BY THINKING AND
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS AND ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE PROPOSED FOR TODAY'S
HEARING- I AM TO KEEP THIS VERY
SHORT AND SWEET THIS BILL IS
SIMPLE AND TO THE POINT IT
MERELY- NAMES THE WORK WE'RE
DOING TO SET UP THE NINE EIGHT
EIGHT SYSTEM WHICH WILL PROVIDE.
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS RESPONSE
AFTER MILES FALL WHO LOCKED LOST
HIS LIFE TRAGICALLY IN MY
DISTRICT AND I CANNOT SAY IT AS
WELL AS HIS MOTHER CAME SO I'M
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO TOWN
HALL. HELLO HELLO MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
THANH HALL AND I'M THE MOTHER OF
MILES FALL WHO SHOT AND KILLED
BY POLICE IN ONE A CREEK
CALIFORNIA WELL EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH EMERGENCY. I'M
ALSO THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE MILE SOUTHBOUND ASIAN.
CREATED TO HONOR MY SON TO MAKE
SURE ANOTHER FAMILY DOESN'T HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THIS BROKEN MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. THAT IS SET UP TO
SET TO CRIMINALIZE THOSE WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THIS NEW BILL AB.
ONE NINE EIGHT EIGHT WILL GIVE
AND SOME PEOPLE LIKE MILES A
CHANCE TO LIVE MILES HAD HIS
WHOLE LIFE AHEAD OF. HIM AT
TWENTY THREE HIS FUNNY SWEET.
AND LIKE TO MAKE RAP BEATS MILES
HAD A SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS AND
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND IT WAS SICK.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REBECCA BARKHANE AND ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THE MILES HALL.
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE WILL GIVE
ALL CALIFORNIA'S ANOTHER
LIFESAVING OPTION BESIDES
CALLING NINE ONE ONE. OUR FAMILY
NEEDED AN ITEM NUMBER ANOTHER
NUMBER TO CALL ON JUNE SECOND.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT WAS
STAFF WITH MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. POLICE DO NOT
HAVE THIS EXTENSIVE TRAINING IN
THIS FIELD. MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR UNDERSTANDING THE
URGENCY TO ROUTE REVITALIZED.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND BEING PART OF THE
PART IN TIME IN HISTORY. WHERE
PROACTIVE CARE IS AN OPTION. OUR
FAMILY IS GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO REDUCE THE TRAGIC
OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS. AND BE HAVE A
LIFESAVING RESOURCES ESPECIALLY
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR LIKE MY SON
MILES. TO GIVE THEM A BETTER
CHANCE OF SURVIVAL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMITMENTS. AND
WANTING TO SEE A BETTER
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL PEOPLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU YOUR HONOR SO
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS. THANK YOU
THEN YOUR SECONDARY THIS PRODUCT
I'M JUDY CROWDERIN MY LEGS
DIRECTOR OF NAMI AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY ANTON ACTUALLY CAME
TO NAMI AND TOOK OUR FAMILY
CLASS POSITIONING HERSELF TO
PROMOTE BETTER OUTCOMES FOR HER
SON SO IN OUR CLASS WE ACTUALLY
SHARE WITH FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
THEY SHOULD MAKE CONTACT WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE WELL AWARE THAT
SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN THAT HOME
LOVE THE INDIVIDUAL WE KNOW THAT
MENTAL ILLNESS IS NOT A CRIME
AND SO WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE ED
HONORED THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
SOMEONE IN OUR- IN OUR AREA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REBEKAH BUYER
CARE. QUE HAN WHO ARE HEARD OUR
PLEA ED HAS ACTUALLY A MISSION
INITIATED EFFORTS IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY MOUNTAINS ARE READY
SAVING LIFE WE'D LIKE TO SAVE
LIVES ACROSS THE STATE WITH THAT
A. B. ONE NINE EIGHT EIGHT
MEMBER BEING IMPLEMENTED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- NEXT WANTED TO ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- THAT. MAYBE
HERE IN THE ROOM. IF WE HAVE
ANYBODY. THAT IS SUPPORTING THIS
BILL LOOKING LIKE- AND THEN I DO
NOT BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION BUT DO WE HAVE ANY.
OPPOSITION MISTER MONEY. WE DO
NOT SO WE WILL THEN OPEN UP THE
PHONE. I'M TALKING WITHOUT THE
MICHAEL. SO ALL RIGHT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT A WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE ROOM SO WE WILL OPEN THE
PHONE LINES. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY. UNLADEN GERMAN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. A
MANAGER AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NOBODY IN OUR QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
IN DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THE TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE IN OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU
MISTER PHONE MONITOR A MODERATOR
I AND I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE. HELLO WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YEAH. A I DON'T.
AND WE'RE- ALL RIGHT WITH THAT-
WE- MMHM YES I JUST WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND SHARING
YOUR SON STORY AND FOR TURNING
INCREDIBLE TRAGEDY INTO AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE TAKE CARE. OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEAR TO US M. TO
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FOR THIS BILL AND
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE. LIFESAVING
CONNECTIONS. FOR PEOPLE HO ARE
IN VULNERABLE MOMENTS SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR KNOWLEDGE AND
- ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. DO WE WANT TO TAKE ROLL
Y'ALL TO WORRY WE STILL DON'T
HAVE A CAR OKAY WE NEED ONE MORE
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THEN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE ACTUALLY COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ALAMEDA AND
THANK- TIME FOR HER BRAVERY AND
SHE REALLY DID TAKE THE WORST
DAY OF ANY MOTHER'S LIFE AND
TURN IT INTO A PASSION. FOR
MAKING THE WORLD SAFER FOR OTHER
PEOPLE'S CHILDREN AND I AM SO
GRATEFUL IT IS NOT EASY TO DO
WHAT SHE HAS DONE TODAY AND
CONTINUES TO DO AND TELL HER
STORY TO SAVE OTHER LIVES SO TO
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BEING SUCH A GREAT PARTNER
TO EVERY FAMILY NEEDS IT AND
THIS COMMITTEE. FOR CONTINUING
THIS IMPORTANT WORK WITHOUT
ASKING EITHER. YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE IN YOUR
TESTIMONY WE APPRECIATE IT AND
AT THIS POINT WE CAN'T VOTE ON
THIS SO WE WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. AND STAY TUNED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.
FROM HOMELESSNESS.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER AUTHORS
HERE I DO NOT SEE ANY OTHER
AUTHORS HERE. AFTER. IF WE CAN
GET THE SERGEANTS TO CHECK ON
OUR MEMBERS PLEASE.
HI MICHAEL. OKAY PLEASE JOIN US
YEAH- LEVINE. WE WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM SIX AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU'RE ON TIME MR
LEVINE. YOU GET TO JUMP AHEAD SO
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING. AB.
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE. YEAH
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY YEAH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE. MICHAEL GOOD ZERO
APPLICANTS AMANDA COMPLETELY. I
FELT I WAS PROBABLY SENT
RECALLED MORE RECENTLY THAN YOU
I JUST GOT HERE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE WOULD
REQUIRE THAT LOCAL PUBLIC ACCESS
CHANNELS BE DELIVERED. TO THE
PUBLIC IN HIGH DEFINITION OR THE
MOST ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY USED BY
LOCAL BROADCAST TELEVISION
CHANNELS IMPORTANTLY THIS WOULD
ENSURE THAT ANY DOCUMENTS
PRESENTED AT GOVERNMENT MEETINGS
ARE READABLE WOULD MAKE CAPTIONS
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
HEARING IMPAIRED OR DEAF. IN THE
PAST FIFTEEN YEARS SINCE THE
DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN VIDEO
COMPETITION ACT ALSO KNOWN AS
DEATH BECAUSE- IT WAS ENACTED
THERE HAVE BEEN MASSIVE CHANGES
TO THE TECHNOLOGIES AND SERVICES
PROVIDED BY VIDEO SERVICES.
VIDEO SERVICE PROVIDERS JUSTIN
THE PANDEMIC WE'VE SEEN
TECHNOLOGY USE DRAMATICALLY
CHANGE THE WAY WE IS ELECTED
OFFICIALS INTERACT WITH THE
PUBLIC WITH MANY PUBLIC MEETING
SHIFTING TO BEING VIRTUAL AND
UTILIZING PLATFORMS LIKE ZOOM
WHILE DIFFICULT REQUIRES THAT
LOCAL PEG ACCESS CHANNELS BE
PROVIDED BY CABLE AND VIDEO
SERVICE PROVIDERS. IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE THOSE CHANNELS TO BE
DELIVERED AN UP TO DATE FORMAT
SUCH AS HIGH DEFINITION IN
PRACTICE THIS HAS ALLOWED THE
VIDEO SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
DOWNGRADE THE PEG ACCESS CHANNEL
SIGNALS AND BROADCAST THE
PROGRAMMING IN THE OBSOLETE
STANDARD DEFINITION FORMAT. AS A
RESULT DETAILED INFORMATION
DISPLAYED DURING ZOOM DELIVER
PUBLIC MEETINGS IS UNCLEAR AND
UNREADABLE SINCE SD VIDEO IMAGES
ARE NOT CLEARLY DISPLAYED ON HD
TELEVISIONS AUDIENCES THAT ARE
DEAF OR HEARING IMPAIRED AND
RELY ON CAPTIONING WILL OFTEN
SEE THOSE CAPTIONS ALLEGEDLY. OR
NOT AT ALL WHEN H. D. PROGRAM IS
DOWNGRADED TESTY. AB TWENTY SO
THIRTY FIVE. DOES NOT INCREASE
COSTS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
ANYWAY THE VAST MAJORITY OF
GOVERNMENTAL EDUCATIONAL AND
COMMUNITY PROGRAMMING IS ALREADY
PRODUCED IN HIGH DEF. ANY
REMAINING USAGE OF STANDARDIZED
MISSION IS PROTECTED IN THE
BILL'S LANGUAGE THE ONLY MANDATE
IN AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE IS
THAT H. DEPRIEST VIDEOS NOT BE
DOWNGRADED. TO A LOWER
TRANSMISSION STANDARD AND IT IS
PRODUCED IN AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING
EQUITABLE AND MEANINGFUL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO PUBLIC PROGRAMMING
INCLUDING GOVERNMENT MEETINGS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. AND I SEE YOU HAVE TO
WITNESSES HERE. ALL UP I'M SORRY
WE'RE GONNA JUMP IN IT LOOKS
LIKE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM CAN WE
GET THE SECRETARY TO CALL THE
ROLL. QUIRK-SILVA HERE COOK
QUIRK-SILVA PRESIDENT PATTERSON
PATTERSON PRINCE PRESENT BOERNER
HORVATH. MIA BONTA HERE YEAH
BONTA PRESENTS THAT AMOUNT THIS
SAID ABOUT THIS PRESENT DAVIES
DAVIS PRESENT A LOT OF THE
LATICIA. HOLDEN LOW. MAIENSCHEIN
RODRIGUEZ VIOLADAS. SENATE
MYELITIS PLAY ABOUT IS HERE. DR
WEBER DR WEBER HERE. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND AT THIS
POINT I'D LIKE TO MOVE OUR
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY
DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
. THE MOTION HEREBY MISTER
PATTERSON AND SECOND VICE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES MMHM
OKAY. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS AB. TWO ZERO SIX SIX BY SAY APPLE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MAN
IN REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH CONSENT AND. AB. TWO TWO FIVE SIX
QUIRK-SILVA DO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
WITH RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
QUIRK-SILVA HI QUIRK-SILVA I'D
PATTERSON PATTERSON HI.
BERNHARDT FOREIGNER HORVATH MIA
BONTA HI MIA BONTA I SAID ABOUT
THIS SAID ABOUT THIS HI DAVIES
DAVIES I EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I WRITE A LOT AS-
ROYALIST HI DOCTOR WEBER DR
WEBER BY. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT-
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES OR THE
CONSENT ITEMS AND WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON WITH THAT WE WILL GO
TO OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MICHAEL
LIZA MAKER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMUNITY MEDIA
CENTER MARIN. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINE WE HAVE OPERATED MARIN TV'S
THREE PUBLIC ACCESS CHANNELS. OF
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
GOVERNMENTAL ALSO REFERRED TO AS
HECK. OUR CHANNEL SERVICING
ENTIRE COUNTY OF MARIN AN
ESTIMATED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS. WHICH IS THE
MAJORITY OF THE COUNTY. THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR ACCOUNTING
MORAN TEND TOWARD OLDER FOLKS SO
THEY PREFER WATCHING TELEVISION
RATHER THAN WATCHING. MEETINGS
ON ANOTHER COMPUTER- ARE
CHANNELS DELIVER TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND HOURS OF PROGRAMMING
EACH YEAR. AND OUR GOVERNMENT
CHANNEL ALONE CARRIES A MEETINGS
OF TEN LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES THE
COUNTY AND NUMEROUS AGENCIES
MOST OF WHICH ARE CARRIED LIVE.
OUR CURRENT CABLE PROVIDERS ARE
COMCAST AND AT&T. THE MAJORITY
OF THOSE ARE COMCAST SINCE AT&T
IS SINCE DISCONTINUED UNIVERSE
FOR NEW SUBSCRIBERS- AS MARK
MENTIONED ARE CHANNELS FOR.
CABLE KHAIRUL ARCTIC CHANNELS
ARE GENERATED IN HIGH DEFINITION
BUT THE CABLE OPERATOR RELAYS
THEM TO SUBSCRIBERS IN SANDARD
DEF. THAT'S REDUCING A SIXTEEN
BY NINE IMAGE TO FOUR BY THREE.
IT SQUEEZES EVERYTHING
EVERYTHING BECOMES BLURRY
SMALLER. AND ILLEGIBLE. IT'S
ALSO DEGRADED BECAUSE THAT
REDUCES THE NUMBER OF PIXELS BY
EIGHTY PERCENT. SO IT'S A HUGE
LOSS OF RESOLUTION- OUR NEED FOR
HD CARRIAGE IS QUITE SIMPLE.
IT'S REQUIRED TO EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATE THE VISUAL
INFORMATION BEING CONVEYED BY
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
AGENCIES TO THEIR CONSTITUENTS
WERE OFTEN CALLED UPON TO CARRY
SPECIAL LIVE. PROGRAMMING IN THE
PAST WITH THE- OF LIFE BRIEFINGS
FOR WILDFIRE EVENTS PROVIDE
HEALTH UPDATES. ALL SORTS OF
THINGS THOSE ARE FULL OF VISUAL
GRAPHICS THAT BECOME ILLEGIBLE.
SO WE REALLY NEED HD- EQUIPMENT. THE TONIGHT SHOW SIR THERE'S
THREE PIECES THE FIRST IS A PEGS
CENTERS ABILITY TO DELIVER HD
WE'VE HAD THAT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE SECOND AS
THE TRANSPORT THAT CITY FIBER
FROM OUR CENTER TO THE CABLE HAD
AND WE'VE HAD THAT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE VIRTUALLY EVERY
CABLE CENTER HAS THE STOMACH AND
THE- STATE. THE THIRD IS THE
CABLE HEAD AND- WHICH- THEN
RELAYS THAT SIGNAL TO ALL THE
CABLE SUBSCRIBERS. AND IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. OUR FIBER
ENCODERS WERE UPGRADED HD
COMCAST WAS UPGRADING THE HEAD
AND- THEY NEEDED TO MAKE IT MORE
EFFICIENT. SO SINCE THAT TIME
WE'VE HAD ABILITY THAT HAD THE
ABILITY TO DELIVER OUR CHANNELS
IN HD THEY CHOOSE NOT TO. THE
ENGINEERS WILL SAY. IT'S A FLIP
OF A SWITCH- BUT YOU HAVE TO
TALK TO MANAGEMENT. SO THAT'S
REALLY WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
AND- WE NEED THIS TERRIBLY- OUR
VIEWERS DEMANDED. THE QUESTIONS
I GET ASKED MOST OFTEN- BY
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND VIEWERS IS
WIDER CHANNELS LOOK SO BAD. AND
YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE DO TO FIX
IT. AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR- GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE- MY NAME IS SUE BUS SKI
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR COMMUNICATIONS
DEMOCRACY. I WORKED IN THE CABLE
COMMUNICATIONS BILL SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. THE GOAL
OF AB AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE
IS THE HELP PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
GOVERNMENT CHANNELS APPEAR LIKE
ANY OTHER CHANNEL ON CABLE
SYSTEM. IT WAS ALWAYS OF CREATED
LOCAL PROGRAMMING FOR YEARS SO
WHY ISN'T DELIVERED IN HD.
BECAUSE DIFFICULT OUR STATE LAW
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE CABLE
PROVIDERS TO DELIVER AN HD- ON
PIG TAILS ARE A LIFELINE FOR
SENIORS VOLATILE PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T COMFORTABLE USING THE
INTERNET OR- DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO BROADBAND OR- OR OR JUST
CAN'T REPORT. DURING THE CALL
THE PANDEMIC THEY CONNECTED WITH
CITY GOVERNMENTS SCHOOLS AND
CHURCH SERVICES THROUGH THE USE
OF THE PAY CHANNELS. OVER THERE
TO WATCH PAID PROGRAMMING-
INSIDE THE THICK BLACK FRAME
WITH UNREADABLE CAPTIONS FUZZY
GRAPHICS ELLEN THIS IS BECAUSE
OF THAT NASTY NOT HD EVEN THOUGH
THE CONTENT IS CREATED IN HD.
YOUR SACRAMENTO COMCAST
DELIVERED HUNDREDS OF CHANNELS
OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTY OF
THOSE CHANNELS ARE DELIVERED IN
BOTH HD AND SD INCLUDING MANY
SHOPPING CHANNELS TWENTY FIVE
SPORTS CHANNELS AND THIRTY
PREMIUM CHANNELS LIKE HBO. YEAH
WE'RE TOLD BY THE CABLE INDUSTRY
THAT I FEEL COMMUNITY CHANNELS
AVAILABLE IN HD AND THE ESTEY IS
JUST NOT GOOD USE A BAND WITH.
BECAUSE THERE'S LIMITED
VIEWERSHIP. BUT LET'S FACE IT
THE OLD FASHIONED CONCEPT OF
LIMITED VIEWERSHIP ISN'T
RELEVANT TODAY. TODAY EVERY
CHANNEL HAS LIMITED VIEWERSHIP
THERE THOUSANDS OF CHANNELS ON
TV RATINGS THAT ONLY FIVE OF THE
HUNDRED FIFTY NETWORKS. ARE THAT
ARE ARE WATCHED BY 1% OF THE US
POPULATION. IN FACT NEARLY HALF
OF THOSE ARE WATCHED. BY LESS
THAN ONE TENTH OF 1% CALIFORNIA
BELIEVE IN THE FOR OF OUR CAN
COULD TECH OBVIOUSLY. YEP
PENSION IN NINETEEN OTHER
STATES. HAVE BEEN DELIVERED IN
H. D. FOR MANY YEARS THE PAY
CHANNELS IN PORTLAND IN THE
SUBURBS OF PORTLAND AS AN
EXAMPLE. HAVE AND HAD EACH
DEEPER EIGHT YEARS AND THEY HAVE
EIGHT CHANNELS DELIVERED IN HD.
ON AS WELL AS AT SPEED SINCE
THEIR CABLE FRANCHISES
RENEGOTIATED THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR
THE BASIC NEEDS LIKE UPDATING
TECHNOLOGY OR OR CONSUMER
PROTECTION CAN BE DEALT WITH AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF DIFFICULT
WE HAVE TO DO IT AT THE STATE
LEVEL. SO LET'S CATCH UP WITH
OTHER STATES AND MAKE SURE THAT
OUR LOCAL EVENT COVERAGE
GOVERNMENT MEETINGS. ALL OF THAT
CONTENT IS IN THE HIGH QUALITY
THAT'S ALREADY PRODUCED. ON OUR
SENIOR SHOULD SEIZE CITY COUNCIL
MEETINGS OUR CHURCH SERVICES AND
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION. WITH
CLEAN VIEWABLE IMAGES AND IN
TODAY'S WORLD IS HD. THANK YOU-
WITH THAT DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM. WHAT SUPPORT
YEAH CHEN MEMBERS CATALINA
SANCHEZ WITH CORBIN AND KAISER
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. VIDEO ALL RIGHT AND
WITH THAT THEN WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WITHOUT ANYBODY
TESTIFYING. BECAUSE OPPOSITION.
FIFTY MADAM CHAIR AT MEMBERS
BERNIE OROZCO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
GREAT DISCUSSION WHAT YOU HEARD
THERE IS NO TECHNOLOGICAL
CHALLENGE HERE THIS IS ABOUT
ABILITY TO PAY SO- THE GYM IS
VERY CORRECT ABOUT HAVING A
FIBRE LINE FROM THE STUDIO TO
ARE HEADED BECAUSE HD CONTENT
TAKES THREE TIMES MORE BANDWIDTH
THAN STANDARD THAT DEFINITION
TELEVISION. AND THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME PAID CHANNELS THAT HAVE
UPGRADE BUT THEY HAVE PAID FOR
THEIR UPGRADE TO THE FIBER LINE
HAVE PAID FOR THE UPGRADE AT THE
HEAD AND THEY HAVE PAID FOR THE
CHANNEL SO THIS IS AN ISSUE OF
DO YOU WANT TO VOTE TO GIVE AWAY
SOMETHING FOR FREE THAT PAKE AT
YOUR RIGHT DIFFICULT REQUIRES
PAID TO BE IN THE BASIC TIER OF
THE CABLE BREAKS- PAIGAH-
PACKAGE SO THAT'S WHERE PEAK OF
THAT THAT IS IN STATURE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SIX. ANY UPGRADE TO
AN HD CHANNEL THOSE ARE PREMIUM
CHANNELS THAT'S WHERE YOU GET A
THE OTHER CHANNELS ARE PREMIUM
THERE IS AN ABILITY FOR THESE TO
DO THAT IT IS TO SAY PORTION OF
DO THEY WANT TO PAY FOR THAT OR
NOT- WE DO GIVE EVERY COMMUNITY
1% OF OUR GROSS RECEIPTS NOT
PROFITS ARE GROSS RECEIPTS TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR ANY
KIND OF CAPITAL UPGRADE. THIS IS
PERMISSIBLE SO WITH THAT 1% OF
THE PAKE FEE THAT WE PAY
COMMUNITIES THEY CAN USE THOSE
FUNDS FOR CAPITAL COSTS WE ALSO
PAY LOCAL COMMUNITIES ANOTHER 5%
OF OUR GROSS RECEIPTS AGAIN NOT
PROFITS GROSS RECEIPTS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO USE AS THEY
CHOOSE SO THIS IS MORE OF A
QUESTION OF A BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP SO I THINK THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL IS TRYING
TO GET IN BETWEEN DISCUSSIONS
OTHER PAID CHANNELS HAVE UPGRADE
TO HD CHANNELS BUT THEY'RE PAID
FOR IT SO. ARE WE LOOKING FOR A
FREE LUNCH HERE OR WHAT IS WHAT
IS THE PLAN THAT. IS A QUESTION
FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FIRST IN SUPPORT. AND LET
ME KNOW IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. A MANAGER AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE ABOUT THIRTEEN IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH LINE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY WILL BE
CREMATED JEFF SCHOTT I'M THE
PRODUCTION MANAGER DAVID
COMMITTEE ACT THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN EDUCATIONAL ACT THE STATE'S
IN THE DAVIS CALIFORNIA AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWO SIXTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GERALD DAY
I REPRESENT ACCESS TO QUALITY IN
SONORA CALIFORNIA SENATE STRONG
SUPPORT AB. TWENTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER FORTY. HELLO MY NAME IS SHANNON KERN
FROM THE STREET THE LEADER AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SIX SIX. TEXAS NUMBER THIRTY
NINE. A LOT THIS IS SEAN
MCLAUGHLIN WITH ACCESS HUMBOLDT
IN EUREKA AND WE SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION. MIXES NUMBER TWENTY
TWO. YES GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
THIS IS TRACING CLOSING THE- OF
THE MEDIA ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SIX THREE
FIVE. BUT A NUMBER THIRTY TWO.
HELLO BRIAN HARLEY FROM THE
COMMUNITY MEDIA AXIS
COLLABORATIVE IN FRESNO AND I'D
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWO SIX
THREE FIVE THANK YOU. SIX WILL
BE NUMBER THIRTY ONE. THIS IS
THE EARLY START FROM CARE C. T.
TELEVISION AND OCEANSIDE
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE. NUMBER TWENTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
MORE KOLINSKI WITH THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE IN SUPPORT. I READ A
NUMBER THIRTY. HELLO MY NAME IS
TYLER TAYLOR CHAIRPERSON OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY SENIOR KERR
COMMISSION I AM IS STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NUMBER. THIRTY SIX. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KHAN AS
SORRY I MIGHT BERKELEY COMMUNITY
MEDIA HERE IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. NUMBER FORTY
ONE. HI MY NAME IS ZACH GENTRY
G. AND I AM STATION MANAGER FOR
LIBERTY TO MAKE YOU TELEVISION
AND SEND DAVIS COMMUNITIES OF
TELEVISION AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. NUMBER. THIRTY
EIGHT. HELLO MY NAME IS RANDY
VAN DALTON I'M A MEMBER OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR COMMUNITY MEDIA IN
A LONG TIME CABLE SUBSCRIBER IN
SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE. NUMBER
TWENTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS KEN
TOREN I'M A BOARD MEMBER OF J.
CAT PUBLIC MEDIA SERVING LOS
GATOS MONTH TO SERENA CALIFORNIA
. AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE. NUMBER
TWENTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRIS MILLER I'M THE CEO OF
PASADENA MEDIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS CHAD
JOHNSON I'M THE CEO OF CREATE TV
SAN JOSE AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB TWO SIX THREE FIVE THANK YOU. NUMBER THIRTY FOUR. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME MIGHT PLAN TO
GET IT S. C. H. T. T. V. IN THE
ROLE COUNTY OF SHASTA IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
DEFINITELY NEED THIS BILL WE
SUPPORT IT UNDER PERCENT A. B.
TWO SIX THREE FIVE IS CRUCIAL.
THANK YOU. THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. WE HAVE
ANYBODY. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION ONLINE. ILLEGAL
GERMAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q. ALRIGHT
AND THEN PUT IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I'M GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR- FOR THIS BILL I WOULD LIKE
TO JUST- HAVE YOU ADDRESSED THE
COMMENTS FROM THE OPPOSITION AS
FAR AS THIS BILL- WE WOULD BE
INTERFERING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RELATIONSHIP MIKE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
DEALT WITH ON A LOCAL LEVEL AND
I ALSO HAVE A QUESTION ARE THERE
ANY OTHER. COMPANIES THAT HAVE
UPGRADED. YES SO ESSENTIALLY-
THE IT'S NOT THAT THEY HAVE
UPGRADED. TYPICALLY LIKE IN THIS
INSTANCE THAT MISTRY'S MUNGER IT
HAD MENTIONED. IT IS BEING
CONVEYED IN HD IT WAS PRODUCING
HD IT'S GOING TO BE CONVEYED IN
HD. IN THIS INSTANCE THEY'RE
CHOOSING NOT TO WHY BECAUSE IT
COMPETES WITH SAY HI IS WATCHING
SOMETHING ELSE RIGHT THERE THE
COST. IS LITTLETON A THING
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION CAN'T
TELL US WHAT THAT COST WOULD BE
THEY DON'T WANT. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR IMPORTANT
INFORMATION THAT. THEY NEED TO
YOU KNOW DISCUSS NEGOTIATED
PUBLIC ACCESS WE CONDUCT OPEN
MEETINGS PEOPLE GET ACCESS TO
THROUGH DECCA- PEOPLE DON'T
WATCH THAT BECAUSE I'D RATHER
THEM. ONTO THE BUS SOMETHING ON
DEMAND OR WATCH SOMETHING WITH
TV COMMERCIALS SOMETHING THAT'S
PROFITABLE RATHER THAN WHAT IT
HAD ALREADY BEEN NEGOTIATED- SO
I KIND OF CHOKED ON THAT FREE
LUNCH COMMENT. RIGHT THAT'S
THAT'S THEIR OBLIGATION UNDER
THE NOTE NEGOTIATION UNDER
DIFFICULT. THAT WE ALL BENEFIT
FROM BECAUSE GOVERNMENT IS OPEN
THAT WAY BUT YOU CAN'T ACTUALLY
LEARN ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
COULD YOU CAN'T READ THE
INFORMATION. ON WHAT IS THE
POINT OF THAT SO THAT THAT'S
THAT'S MY RESPONSE OKAY BUT MY
QUESTION IS- ARE THERE ANY
COUNTIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE TRANSMITTING. HI THERE
LOCAL YET YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND SO
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN SO IT. IT
HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE CHOOSE TO DO
THE CONVEYANCE. COMPETITIVE TO
NOT ALLOW THAT PUBLIC ACCESS
PROGRAMMING TO COME AWAY AND A
COME A CALL ACROSS TO BE
BROADCAST IN A WAY THAT CAN BE-
CONSUME TO US THAT PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND THE INFORMATION A
GOVERNMENT OR OTHERS ARE TRYING
TO CONVEY IN THAT. SO YOU'RE SO
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THEY HAVE
DECIDED WHICH COUNTIES ARE GONNA
SHOW EVERY- EVERY COUNTY WELL
MICHAEL YOU PROBABLY TALK ABOUT
THIS DIFFERENTLY. FROM MY TIME
WHEN I WAS ON A LOCAL
TELECOMMUNICATION COMMUNICATIONS
AGENCY FRANCHISES WERE
NEGOTIATED BY LOCAL FRANCHISE
WHICH IS NOT A WHOLE COUNTY- IT
CAN BE. JUST WHATEVER THAT
FRANCHISE SPACES LAW CHANGED TO
GIVE CUT- WHICH GOVERNS IT SINCE
THEN AND IF I'M NOT ACCURATELY
DESCRIBING THAT YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SAY IT A LITTLE BIT
BETTER THAN I CAN YEAH WE'RE
BASICALLY UNDER DIFFICULT LOCAL
FRANCHISE AUTHORITIES WHETHER
THEY BE A COUNTY OR A
MUNICIPALITY. THEY HAVE NO ROOM
TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE CABLE
OPERATOR- DIFFICULT HAS SET THE
RULES AND THAT'S WHAT EVERYONE
HAS TO LIVE BY. SO THE ONLY WAY
THAT YOU CAN. A NOTE CABLE UP.
TO PROVIDE H. CARRIAGE TO THESE
ON- OF PUBLIC INTEREST CHANNELS
WHICH IS A PAY CHANNELS. IS TWO.
YOU KNOW A- YOU KNOW DISCOVER
PASS THIS. LEGISLATION OKAY SO I
JUST WANNA. I JUST I'M A I'M- SO
ARE YOU TELLING ME THAT THERE
ARE NO. LOCAL FOR. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE. THAT THAT
LISTING LOCAL FRANCHISES WERE ON
BOARD- THEY'RE ALL HAVING THE
SAME ISSUE BECAUSE IT SOUNDED TO-ME LIKE. IT COULD BE NEGOTIATED
. WITH NO SIGNIFICA ENDED THE
LOCAL FOR. OUT OF THEM ARE
OPERATE UNDER DISCUSSION- AND
SO. THEY ARE CHOOSING WHEN THEY
WANT TO DO THE CONVEYANCE IN HD
OR NOT AND SO THAT'S THAT'S WHY
IT'S ON US TO THEN TABLE
DIFFICULT DIDN'T ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BUT ANALOG CHANNELS THERE
USED TO BE A LOT OF PUBLIC
ACCESS TV OUT THERE. I LOOK UP
FAR MORE BROAD BROADBAND THEN-
THE H. D. DOES CHAIR I'M SORRY I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS LIKE OUT
OF ORDER BUT IS IT POSSIBLE TO
HAVE THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM CC
TA COME UP AND ANSWER SME OF
THESE QUESTIONS AS WELL. BECAUSE
IT I FEEL LIKE I'M HEARING TWO
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THINGS AND-
IT. WELL- HE WE WANT TO GET.
TRANSPARENT CONVERSATION GOING
HERE SO THEY'RE ABLE TO ANSWER
SO LET ME HAVE COMCAST-
REPRESENTATIVE COME UP AND
ADDRESS SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I
DO WISH HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
AND WHAT THE OPPOSITE. COMCAST
HAD SAID WAS REGARD PLEADED TO
PAY IN FOR. SO BRANCH RIGHT- THE
WASHINGTON THREE THOUSAND SIX.
CORRECT IN THAT IN THAT REGARD.
THERE IS NO PROVISION HOWEVER
FROM NEGOTIATING ADDITIONAL
PROVISION FOR YOUR CANNOT BE YOU
CHOOSE TO ENTER INTO AGREEMENT
WITH YOUR PROVIDER YOU CAN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE HAVE HD YOU CAN'T
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU FOR.
THE DISCUSS THEIR- HAS EVERY OF
THE MINIMUMS THAT WE HAVE TO
MEET AND THAT IS THAT WE MY
PROVIDE. PAID CHANNEL THE LOCAL
WHERE WE PROVIDE THE SERVICE IN
ADDITION SO THAT THAT'S A FREE
CHANNELS WITH A LOT OF MONEY SO
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE MUST GIVE
THEM. 1% OF OUR GROSS RECEIPTS
TO USE FOR THE STUDIOS FOR THIS
PICTURE HILLS. AND WE MUST GIVE
THEM ANOTHER 5% OF OUR GROSS
RECEIPTS TO USE ANYWHERE THEY
WANT IN THEIR GENERAL FUND. NOW
THE NUMBER OF PICK UP FOR US UP
THERE. I JUST AND JUST THE
NUMBER OF PAID CHANNELS PLUS.
CORRECTLY DURING THE OLD LOCAL
FRANCHISING DAYS WHEN WE DID
NEGOTIATE INDIVIDUALLY CITY BY
CITY COUNTY BY COUNTY THEY
NEGOTIATE THE NUMBER OF CHANNELS
THAT THEY WANT. SO THOSE
CHANNELS WERE GRANDFATHERED IN
SO IF MARIN HAD FIVE PATIENTS IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX THEY KEPT THOSE
FIVE PATIENTS A DAY I DON'T KNOW
WHAT NUMBER YOU HAVE FOR MARIN
BUT- AS AN EXAMPLE. AND THEN
THERE IS A BARE MINIMUM THAT FOR
ANY NEW COMMUNITIES THAT YOU GET
A STATE FRANCHISE THAT YOU MUST
PROVIDE A MINIMUM- PICTURE FOR
THAT COMMUNITY. OKAY SITES ALL
ASK YOU THIS SO ESSENTIALLY WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. IS THAT DIFFICULT
THE- ESTABLISH THE FLOOR BUT NOT
THE CEILING. CORRECT OKAY AND SO
. THAT BEING SAID IF A LOCAL
FRANCHISE A LOCAL ENTITY WANTED
MORE THAN WHAT DIFFICULT OFFERS
THEY COULD STILL NEGOTIATE WITH
YOU ALL FOR THAT. CORRECT SO IF
IT LOCAL FRANCHISING IT IF A
LOCAL AGENCY- PAKE JANET WANTED
TO UPGRADE TO HIGH DEFINITION
TELEVISION. IT AND AGAIN THAT
TAKES THREE TIMES MORE BANDWIDTH
THAN STANDARD DEFINITION YOU
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A FIGHT A
DEDICATED FIBER LINE FROM THE
STUDIO TO THE HEAD AND THEN YOU
MUST UPGRADE THE EQUIPMENT AT
THE HEAD AND YOU MUST HAVE HD
CHANNEL TO IT TO GET THAT ALL TO
WORK SO IT LIKE CHANNEL THREE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHEN YOU SEE
CHANNEL THREE. IT'S IN THE BASIC
TIER- IS CHANNEL THREE BUT IF
YOU WANT TO SEE HIGH DEFINITION
CHANNELS THREE PAYS FOR HIGH
DEFINITION TO A CHANNEL THAT
PARALLELS THAT CHANNEL THREE
IT'S LIKE GENERAL MOTORS SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN OR
SOMETHING. SO IT'S A HIGHER TIER
BUT IT THAT THAT H. D. TIER IS A
DIFFERENT HERE THAN THE BASIC
CABLE WHICH IS DIFFICULT.
SPECIFIES THAT WE PROVIDE THE
PAY CHANNELS IN STANDARD
DEFINITION. I'M GONNA- IF WE
OTHER MAY. AND THEN WE CAN BACK
BUT- OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION AND DIFFERENT
OPINIONS ON THAT SO LET'S GO
HEAD TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA I
ALSO IT WAS JUST TRYING TO GET A
LITTLE BIT AT THE CALCULUS THAT
THAT BUT THE COST FACTOR
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS SO- I HEARD
OPPOSITION TALK ABOUT SIX
PERCENT. OF IT YOU KNOW GROSS
PROCEEDS GOING ALREADY TO LOCAL
CHANNELS- I ALSO HEARD SOME
SPECIFICITY AROUNDS- THE
SPECIFIC THAT THE USE OF THOSE
FUNDS. I'M FOR INFRASTRUCTURE I
WOULD LIKE TO GET A SENSE OF THE
OVERALL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH-
BEING ABLE TO CONVERT TO AN HD
WHICH IS. THAT THE SUBSTANCE OF
THIS. MS AND THE POTENTIAL COST
BURDEN. TO THE LOCAL. WELL I
MEAN I. THE IS THERE RIGHT SO
YOU'RE PRODUCING IN HD MOST OF
THESE PLACES HAVE ALL THE
CAPACITY TO DO HD- IT IS A
CHOICE NOT TO PROVIDE H. D. I
THINK THAT IT WOULD BE GOING
DOWN THE WRONG ROAD TO SAY. THAT
WE SHOULD BE TREATING A PEG-
CHANNEL WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY PER
PROVIDES ESSENTIAL INFORMATION
SERVICES LIKE OPEN GOVERNMENT
MEETINGS WITH AN NBC AFFILIATE.
WHICH IS WHAT MR ROSCOE JUST AT
THAT THAT'S NOT THE SAME THING.
AND SO- I DO THIS IDEA THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE COSTING LOTS
OF MONEY THEY THEY CAN'T
QUANTIFY THAT BAND WITH EXISTS
THE TECHNOLOGY IS THERE TO
SUPPORT THAT THEY'RE CHOOSING
IN. WHEN THEY DECIDE TO. S. B.
O. G. AT GEOGRAPHICAL AREA TO
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA SUMMER
CHOOSING TO CONVEY IT IN HD. AND
OTHERS ARE DOWNGRADING THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY A CHOICE THAT THEY
ARE MAKING- AND SO THIS BILL
SAYS WHEN YOU HAVE H. THE A BIT
AVAILABILITY. AND WHEN THINGS
HAVE BEEN PRODUCED IN HD PLEASE
CONVEY AND H. D. SO PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY. SEE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MEETINGS AND READ THE
THINGS THAT ARE BEING SHARED.
YEAH AND- WE HAVE A- AND FOR I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND LET OUR NEXT
MEMBER ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID USE
AND ASK A QUESTION THANK YOU- I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
WOULD WANT TO UPGRADE THAT MAKES
COMMON SENSE TO ME. BUT I GUESS
THAT'S WHERE I'M LOOKING AT
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THEY'RE STOPPING YOU FROM THE
LOCAL- AGENCY TO I'M ACTUALLY
UPGRADE IT'S REALLY GETTING DOWN
TO WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR IT.
AND IF IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
THAT MUCH WHY CAN'T THEY USE IT
FROM THE 5% FRANCHISE FEE OR THE
ONE PERCENT- WHICH IS THE- GROSS
RECEIPTS RECEIPTS. BECAUSE SOME
THEY CAN DO THAT SO THAT IT'S
REALLY THE LOCALITY DECIDING DO
WE WANT TO SPEND THAT MONEY TO
UPGRADE OR DO WE NOT OR MIKE
BEING CONFUSED HERE NO I MEAN I
THINK THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE TAKING-
A TRIP SERVICES RESPECTFULLY AS
I CAN LIKE THAT DEBATE. THAT
THEY WANT THEY WANT THE STATE
NOT TO. MENTION THIS BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO PICK OFF. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND GET MONEY OUT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BROADCAST
LOCAL GOVERNMENT MEETINGS WHICH
THEY ARE ALREADY REQUIRED TO DO.
SO THE MEETINGS ARE ALREADY THAT
PRODUCED IN HD- THEY CAN BE
CONVEYED IN HD THEY'RE CHOOSING
NOT TO DO IT THE THAT THERE IS
NO REAL COST EXCEPT THE COST
THAT THEY WANT TO ENCOURAGE UPON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO DO SOMETHING
THAT THEY CAN ALREADY DO. IN
JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UP FOR ME-
AGAIN IF THEY HAVE 5% HERE 1%
THERE MY CONCERN IS ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER. IS THIS GOING TO END
UP GOING TO THE CONSUMER BECAUSE
THERE'S ALWAYS A COST SO IT'S
EITHER GOING TO HIT THAT. EITHER
IF THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT IT'S
GONNA COME DOWN OR THE LOCAL
LEVELS CAN GO AHEAD AND IT CAN
COME DOWN SO I GUESS THE SAID
THE PRODUCTS THERE NO ONE
STOPPING ANYONE FROM GETTING IT
IT'S REALLY WHO WANTS TO PAY FOR
IT IS WHAT I'M SEEING HERE BUT
THERE'S NOT- THERE'S JUST NO
DAHLE. AMOUNTS THAT THEY'VE SAID
THIS IS WHAT IT WOULD COST. FOR
YOU TO HAVE YOUR INFORMATION.
CONVERTED AND THE HD UNLESS
THEY- WANTED TO CHARGE WHAT THEY
CHARGE. LIKE LESS I MENTIONED. A
LOCAL NBC AFFILIATE. SO THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE THE BAND
WITH IS THERE. THEY CAN JUST
CONVEY IT. THERE'S NO EXTRA.
TOLL TO GET ON THE INFORMATION
SUPERHIGHWAY. IF YOU WILL. FOR
THEM TO THEN. HAVE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MEETING. BE BROADCAST
IN HD SO FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S NOT THE COST
IS. THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO BE
COMPETING. AT WITH MEMBER
STATIONS- SO THAT. THE
ESSENTIALLY YEAH I MEAN I
ESSENTIALLY THERE'S THAT.
BECAUSE I DON'T I DON'T IN THAT
YET SO I YEAH BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK I DON'T THINK LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN REALLY AFFORD TO
COMPETE WITH THE LOCAL. NATIONAL
BROADCAST CHANNEL SO I'M GONNA
BRING IT BACK- AS A CHAIR OF ON
IRAQ- I THINK ONE OF THE
OVERALL. MESSAGES IS HERE IS
WHAT DO OUR PUBLIC CHANNELS
PRESENT TO THE PUBLIC. AND WHY
ARE THEY THERE WITHOUT
DIFFICULTY. AND WHEN WE GET BACK
TO IT WE'RE LOOKING AT OUR
PUBLIC IN WHAT THEY RECEIVE.
FROM THEIR LOCAL WHETHER IT'S
THEIR LOCAL COMCAST OR LOCAL
SPECTRUM. AND THAT IS A SERVICE
AND THE SERVICE IS TO PROVIDE. A
FEW OF YOU ARE COUNCIL BEFORE
AND THOSE ARE TELEVISED BUT IF
IN TURN THEIR TELEVISED
UNANSWERED TRANSMITTED. YOU HAVE
A VERY POOR VIEW OF THAT YOU'RE
REALLY NOT GETTING THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT. AND THAT'S THE INTENDED
FOR DIFFICULT A AND THAT IS WHY
I SUPPORTED THAT. WHO DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THAT WANT TO
COMMENT AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE ABOUT. YEAH SO I AM I AM
WOULD LOVE SOME CLARITY ON ON
COST NEXT YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THERE'S NO COST. BUT CLEARLY IF
YOU WOULD NEED TO RUN FIBER FROM
POINT A TO POINT B. TO GET YOUR
CHANNEL AVAILABLE IN HD THERE
WOULD BE A COST THERE. SO THEY
HAVE OTHER STATION. PAID FOR
THAT PROCESS OF LAYING FIBER AND
THEN I'M ASSUMING THAT THEY'RE
LAYING FIBER AND THEN THEY'RE
ALSO. PAYING FOR THAT H. D.
CHANNEL ACCESS IS THAT CORRECT.
YEAH I MEAN VIRTUALLY ALL THE
PICKCENTER IN THIS. HAVE THE
FIVE CONNECTION OR SOME KIND OF
ADEQUATE CA. THIS BY TO THE
EARLY DAYS OF PUBLIC ACCESS
TELEVISION. UN VAN VIRTUALLY ALL
OF THE ACCESS CENTERS ARE HAVE
MASTER CONTROL CENTER. LAYING
OUT H. DEPROGRAMMING- I KNOW IN
THE CASE OF COMCAST WHEN THEY
DID ARE THEY REPLACED OUR CODERS
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
THAT WAS FOR THEIR BENEFIT
BECAUSE THEY WERE MAKING THEIR
OWN NETWORK MORE EFFICIENT- I
YOU KNOW THE ENGINEER I SPOKE TO
HE SAID THEY WERE DOING THIS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE NOW THE-
COMCAST FRANCHISE. SO THE ONLY
NEEDS TO BE DONE ON ON IN THAT
CASE OF COMCAST IS A SOFTWARE
CONFIGURATION SOMEBODY ASSISTED
DOWN FLIP THE SWITCH- OTHER
OTHER CABLES. UPPER IN OPERATORS
MAY HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS BUT- IN
OUR CASE THAT'S WHAT IT IS ONE
ONE OTHER QUICK OBSERVATION IS
THAT ARGUABLY DIFFICULT ALREADY
REQUIRES THE CABLE OPERATORS TO
PROVIDE THAT THAT CONNECTION
FROM THE CITY HALL OR FROM THE
COMMUNITY MEDIA CENTER. TO THEIR
HEAD AND- HUB SITE OKAY SO WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS. IN
ORDER YET AND AS MICHAEL HAS
SAID. THAT CONNECTION I MEAN IS
ALREADY. IN PLACE OKAY. IT'S NOT
LIKE A NEW CONNECTION HAS TO BE
BUILT IF THEY CHOOSE TO UPGRADE
IT THAT'S THE CABLE OPERATORS
THIS IS TREASON. ABSOLUTELY THEY
HAVE THAT BUSINESS TRIPS BUT
IT'S NOT BECAUSE A NEW LINE HAS
TO BE BUILT. OKAY AS MICHAEL HAS
THEIR OWN WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE IT TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AND I DO HAVE A CLIENT
ONE FOLLOW UP SURE AND NOTICED-
I WOULD I WOULD LOVE SOME
CLARITY ON NOT BECAUSE AND MY-
ALL MY EXPERIENCE YOU DO HAVE TO
UP. IT FIGHTER FIBER YOU WANT TO
BE. A IS. STERN EVER AS OUR
THERE ACTUALLY THE APELO
CHANNELS THAT WE- TOOK MORE BAND
THAN THE KERR. AGE DID CHANNEL
SO AND LAST ALL AT. IS THIS THE
A- VAST SHOULD BE SHOULD WE READ
. I'M DEAF. THAT'S WHAT WAS THE
YEAH. OKAY THIS. I'M THE ONE
SENT A MAN TO DO. OKAY NO. YEAH
THE WAS OUR THERE THIS IS A-
PUBLIC AT. AND I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE WE DIFFICULT IT WITH THEIR
IDEAS GOING TO BE ANOTHER BILL
BROUGHT FORWARD IN OUR COMMITTEE
NOT TODAY. ON DIFFICULT BUT THIS
IS ABOUT ACCESS FOR THE PUBLIC-
I'M GOING TO WIND IT UP HERE AND
LESS I HAVE. ANYMORE COMMENTS DO
WE HAVE A MOTION OR. HELLO TO
HAVE A SECOND. I'M SORRY NO OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HEAD I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S VERY
CLEAR ON THE RECORD BECAUSE THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE ALL KIND
OF TOUCHED ON SO WHAT YOU ARE
TELLING US IS THAT THIS ONE WILL
NOT INCREASE COST TO THE
CONSUMERS. AT ALL. NOT C. H.
ANGE AND THEIR BELL. YES. ALL
RIGHT FOR ALL OF OUR MEMBERS
HERE DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. MAKE SURE YOU GET YOUR
COMMENTS AND WE HAVE A MOTION DO
WE HAVE A SECOND. OH I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T SEE YOU A SECOND BY- MR
RODRIGUEZ AND WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK-SILVA HI
QUIRK-SILVA I. PATTERSON
PATTERSON NO BOERNER HORVATH
YEAH BONTA NOT VOTING MIA BONTA
NOT VOTING SET AMOUNT THIS. DATE
SAID ABOUT THIS I DAVIES DAVIS
NOW A LOT OF THE GOT SCEA LOT OF
THE WEST SEATTLE I HOLDEN. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I WRITE ABOUT IS NO BY ABOUT IS
NO DOCTOR WEBER. DOCTOR WHAT
WEBER YES AND I. ON THIS BILL
WILL REMAIN ON CALL THANK YOU
AND WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO
TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR HERE- IS
NUMBER FOUR AB. TWO TWO FIVE
TWO. THANK YEAH IT WAS. SO YEAH
. OKAY. YES. ARE YOU. THE
FINANCIAL AID OUT OF THE.
WILL BE A LITTLE BIT EASIER
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY TWO WHICH REQUIRES THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
COLLECT INFORMATION A
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS EFFORTS TO REPAIR AND
REPLACE NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
AFTER EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS
BILL. THE WILDFIRES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CAUSED MASSIVE
DEVASTATION FROM PROPERTY LOSS
TO TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORK
DAMAGE MANY PEOPLE REPORT THEIR
MOBILE PHONES WENT DARK AND
INTERNET SERVICE WENT OUT AT
CELL TOWERS WERE DAMAGED AN
UNDERGROUND FIBER LINES BURNED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AN
ONLINE SURVEY SURVEY FOUND THAT
64% OF RESPONDENTS IN CINEMA
COUNTIES WILDFIRE WHAT WILDFIRES
AFFECTED AREAS LOUT THEY LOST
LAND LINE PHONE SERVICE IN
TWENTY TWENTY THE GLASS FOR A
REPORTED DAMAGE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE. DISRUPTIONS IN
PHONE SERVICE IN THE AFFECTED
AREAS. IN THE AFTERMATH OF THESE
DEVASTATING FIRES THE STUDENT
PEERS C. HAVE FOOTBALL FOCUSED
HEAVILY ON THE UTILITIES
RESPONSE TO THE MASSIVE
DESTRUCTION EVEN TODAY LITTLE IS
KNOWN ABOUT THE FULL IMPACT
THESE NATURAL DISASTERS OF HAD
ON TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS
AND HOW TELECOMMUNICATIONS COME
COMPANIES HAVE RESPONDED.
CONCRETE RECOVERY PLANS ARE NOT
SHARED WITH THE P. YOU SEE OR
THE LEGISLATURE WHOSE JOB IT IS
TO OVERSEE THESE COMPANIES AND
REPRESENT THE PUBLIC INTEREST WE
NEED THIS INFORMATION TO MAKE
SURE GOVERNMENTS ARE HELPING IN
THE REPAIR EFFORTS AND NOT
IMPEDING THE RESTORATION. AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO REQUIRES
THE PC T COLLECT INFORMATION
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS EFFORTS TO REPAIR AND
REPLACE NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
AFTER EMERGENCIES OR DID THE OR
DISASTERS. I WANT TO STRESS THAT
THIS BILL. THE BILL'S REQUIRED
REPORTING IS NOT MANDATED TO BE
SUBMITTED DURING THE EMERGENCY
THEMSELVES. BUT IT IS INSTEAD A
LOOK BACK TO MAKE SURE
GOVERNMENT AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WORKING TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS IN THE SHORT
TERM DURING EMERGENCIES AND
APPROPRIATE SERVICE TO SUPPORT
LOCAL ECONOMIES. AFTER DISASTER
IS IN THE FOR THE LONG TERM. AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO IS NEEDED
TO ENSURE THAT STATE REGULATORS
AND PUBLIC OFFICIALS ARE
INFORMED OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
FAILURES. AND NETWORK DAMAGE
AFTER A NATURAL DISASTER WITHOUT
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
METHODS AND TECHNOLOGIES USED TO
REBUILD THERE IS NO WAY TO
ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS HAVE THE
SAME IMPROVE ACCESS TO RELIABLE
NETWORK. FOR MOST CALIFORNIANS
RELIABLE VOICE TELEPHONE ERVICE
IS NECESSARY TO REACH NINE ONE
ONE WITHOUT IT THE ABILITY TO
ACT EMERGENCY SERVICES THIS
LIMITED LIMITED OR NONEXISTENT.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
ANSWER QUESTIONS ARE NOT CO
HERNANDEZ AND REGINA COSTA.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ON VIRGIN ACOSTA I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. DURING THE PAST FEW YEARS
THE IMPORTANCE OF RELIABLE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND BROADBAND
SERVICE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS HAS
BEEN BROUGHT INTO SHARP RELIEF
BY BOTH THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND THE MANY DECLARED
DISASTERS EXPERIENCE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. LAST YEAR THE C. P.
U. E. REQUIRED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT DAMAGE TO INFRASTRUCTURE
CAUSED BY DECLARED DISASTERS
INCLUDING THE DAMAGE TO THE
NETWORKS AND THE STEPS TAKEN TO
REPAIR OR REBUILD. THE CPUC
ACTION ADDRESSED MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS OF A PRIOR BILL AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED THE CPUC DECISION
HIGHLIGHTS THE DESIRE TO ENSURE
DATE ACTION AND REVIEW OF
SERVICE OUTAGES HOWEVER BECAUSE
THE DECISION DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY REFERENCE BROADBAND
WE CAN ENVISION SOME CONFUSION
ON WHICH PROVIDERS AND WHICH
SERVICES ARE COVERED. AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY TWO MAKES CLEAR THAT
ANY ENTITY PROVIDING BROADBAND
WILL HAVE TO REPORT OUTAGE AND
RESTORATION INFORMATION IF THE
BROADBAND SERVICE IS AFFECTED AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO HAS THE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENT THAT THE
CPUC REPORT THIS INFORMATION TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. THERE IS OTHER DATA
COLLECTION UNDERTAKEN BY CAL
NLY US ABOUT TELECOM SERVICE
OUTAGES IN REAL TIME TO SUPPORT
THE WORK OF EMERGENCY OFFICIALS
THE ACTION REQUIRED BY AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY TWO SO. VERY DIFFERENT
PURPOSE WITH THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO CAL- YES ARE
FOCUSED ON IMMEDIATE SAFETY AND
PROVIDING INFORMATION TO
EMERGENCY. OFFICIALS ON THE SPOT
. AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO IS
FOCUSED ON SAFETY AND
RESTORATION OF SERVICES WEAVING
ANY COMMUNITY BEHIND FOLLOWING A
DISASTER RELATED OUTAGE ONLY
EXACERBATES ACCESS TO BROADBAND.
THE REPORT WILL PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE COMMISSION
WITH A LONG TERM PERSPECTIVE ON
THE RELIABILITY OF BROADBAND FOR
ALL COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
HELP INSURE THAT NO COMMUNITY IS
LEFT BEHIND IF THEY'RE BROADBAND
FACILITIES OR DESTROYED. DURING
A DISASTER WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ARE NOT YOUR
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE WHICH
ENCOMPASSES CALIFORNIA NEVADA
AND HAWAII WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE MEASURE.
LET ME JUST FOCUS ON THE PART
ABOUT THE LOOK BACK AS THE
AUTHOR INDICATED THIS BILL WOULD
ENABLE BOTH THE COMMISSION AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO RECEIVE
INFORMATION NOT ONLY ABOUT
OUTAGES BUT ABOUT WHAT STEPS
WERE TAKEN. AND WHETHER WE'RE
SUCCESSFUL AND RISK AVERSE TO
ALL COMMUNITIES THIS LEGISLATORS
WORK VERY DILIGENTLY AS YOU KNOW
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS O INVEST
IN BROADBAND EXPANSION AND
INCREASE ACCESS WE KNOW HOW
CRITICAL IT IS THAT ALL
COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
EVENT OF A LOT OF A DISASTER
WHERE THE NETWORKS ARE DOWN AND
HAVE TO BE REBUILT AND YET WE
ARE NOT AWARE WHETHER ALL
COMMUNITIES HAVE THEIR SERVICE
RESTORED IN A WAY THAT WILL BE
SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM. THAT IS
ANOTHER WAY IN WHICH THERE CAN
BE A GAP IN SERVICE AND LACK OF
ACCESS WITH THIS BILL WILL DO
WELL WILL ENSURE. THAT THE
COMMISSION ON ANNUAL BASIS WILL
RECEIVE INFORMATION FROM THE
COMPANIES THAT BROADBAND SERVICE
WAS RESTORED HOW WAS RESTORED
AND HOW IT WILL REMAIN.
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE IMPACTED BY THE
DISASTER AND THERE WOULD ALSO BE
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS ABOUT ALL OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE COMMUNITIES
IN YOUR DISTRICTS TO ENSURE THAT
SERVICE WAS RESTORED TO CAN HAVE
CONFIDENCE. I'VE HEARD TOO MANY
TIMES IN LEGISLATORS LEGISLATIVE
STAFF WHEN THESE DISASTERS
HAPPEN THAT THEY'RE CALLING
THEIR FRIENDS THEIR LOBBYIST
THEIR CONTACTS AT THE COMPANIES
TO FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED NOT
ONLY IN REAL TIME BUT LONG TERM
WHEN THEY HEAR STORIES FROM
CONSTITUENTS TO SAY. NO ACTUALLY
IT TOOK US A MONTH LONGER THAN
EVERY OTHER COMMUNITY GOOD OR
SERVICE RESTORED WE SHOULD NOT
BE ADDRESSING THE INFORMATION
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A VERY
SUSTAINED OPERATIONAL WAY TO
ENSURE THAT WE WILL GET THIS
INFORMATION TO THE COMMISSION.
AND TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT'S
VERY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THE
INFORMATION IS THE PURPOSE THAT-
YEAH- THE COURT REQUIREMENTS-
YES FOR THOSE REASONS WE'RE
PROUDEST. TO BE A CO SPONSOR ASK
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL. DO
WE HAVE ANY BY IN. THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN IN SUPPORT. I
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO VOICE OPPOSITION. WELL
I'M SURE MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO
AGAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION THIS IS A SONG WE
HEARD BEFORE. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD ON NETWORK
OUTAGES AND RESTORATION TO PC
ADOPTED A VERY SIGNIFICANT
RESILIENCY DECISION THAT
MAPPING OF OUTAGES MAKING SURE
THAT THERE ARE PROPER
INVESTMENTS IN ADVANCED
COMMUNICATIONS INFRASTRUCTURE
AND YOU NEED FOR THIS THIS BILL
IS FOCUSED ON A BROADBAND
SERVICE BUT WE REALLY NEED TO
TALK ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WE
HAVE DONE THIS MAJOR SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS AND CONTINUE TO DO
WORK ON OUR BACKUP POWER FOR
THOSE CONNECTIONS IN ADDITION TO
THAT SENATOR CORKER TWO PIECES
OF LEGISLATION HEARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE SO YOU HAD SB SIX
SEVENTY SB THREE FORTY ONE SB
SIX SEVENTY AS YOU HEARD WAS A
REQUIREMENT THAT NGUYEN WITHIN
THIRTY MINUTES OF AN OUTAGE. A
MAJOR OUTAGE THAT WE HAVE TO
NOTIFY CAL OH YES OF THAT OUTAGE
AND WE HAVE TO LET THEM KNOW
EVERY THIRTY MINUTES WHAT IS THE
PROGRESS OF OUR RESTORATION AND
THEN WE HAVE TO LET ME KNOW WHEN
IT'S BEEN FULLY RESTORED WITH
THE FINAL REPORT. THAT
INFORMATION IS ONLY SHARED WITH
FIRST RESPONDERS BECAUSE IT'S
DEALING WITH EMERGENCIES THE
SITUATION SO. THE P. YOU SEE HAS
A RESILIENCY CAL OH YES HAS A
RESPONSE TO THE DISASTER. THIS
BILL IS SAYING WE WANT THAT TYPE
OF INFORMATION TO COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY DISASTER BY WHAT
HAPPENED SPECIFIC AND SO THAT'S
INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING WITH I'M NOT SURE
WHAT IT IS. BUT SO WHAT WE WOULD
SAY IS THE END THAT REPORT HAS
TO BE MADE PUBLIC. IN THIS AGE
OF- ESPIONAGE ON ONLINE AT THIS
IF YOU WANTED TO KNOW IF I WAS
RUSSIA BELARUS AND I WANT TO
KNOW HOW CAN I TAKE DOWN
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK AND- THE
FIFTH LARGEST COUNTY WERE. ONLY
GOING TO DO IS SIGN UP FOR THE
PC- DISTRIBUTION OF DE. DANIEL
HOW DOES REPORT AND I GOT IT
RIGHT THERE SO THIS IS VERY
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THIS IS
VERY IMPORTANT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT IS PROVIDED
TODAY TO THE PC AGAIN FOR
INVESTMENTS IN RESILIENCY AND TO
CAL OH YES. FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE REAL TIME SITUATION FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS. SO YOU HAVE TO
ASK YOURSELF WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
DO WITH THIS INFORMATION AND
WHAT CAN PUT OUT IN THE PUBLIC
REALM. THAT'S OUR QUESTION FOR
THESE REASONS WERE OPPOSE. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES IF WE HAVE ANYBODY CALLING
IN FOR SUPPORT. EMBLAZONED
GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE TO IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL
START WITH NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TRACY RYAN WITH THE BRO CARE
REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. NEXT UP IS NUMBER FORTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
STAND AND AREA. CENTER VALLEY
AND ALSO- TECHNICIAN- I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO REMIND EVERYBODY
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN WE CAN ALWAYS
LIKE TO SAY THAT THAT WORK OR
OPPOSE. AND YOUR ORGANIZATION-
YEAH OH I'M SORRY YEAH YES SORRY
THANK YOU SPORTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK. ANY OTHER SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. AND
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE
SAID OPPOSITION. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE.
WITHOUT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MEMBERS. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THIS BILL I THINK- IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE AS
A BODY HAVE THE ABILITY TO.
DISCERN INTENT FROM ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION PARTICULARLY IN
TIMES OF CRISIS- ELEMENTS THE
PROVISION OF SUCH AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICES BROADBAND SERVICE SO I
APPRECIATE- THAT THE PUSH
TOWARDS TRANSPARENCY A IN
UNDERSTANDING OUR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY. MAKE RESPONSIBLE
DECISIONS AND SO I THINK WHAT WE
WILL DO WITH IT IS LEGISLATE AND
INSURE AND OVERSIGHT WHICH IS
THAT RESPONSIBILITY- AND
AUTHORITY OF THIS BODY SO THANK
YOU AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU SO. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FORD OVERSEE.
COMMUNICATION IS KEY ESPECIALLY
DURING A DISASTER RESPONSES FROM
TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE HAVE THE
NECESSARY SERVICE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. LOOKING FOR TO SUPPORT
AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE ARE SO I
CAN DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
INTENT OF THE BILL- I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS AND YOU KNOW
SPECIFICALLY JUST THE PAST
COUPLE DAYS IF YOU LOOK IN THE
NEWS. THE U. S. WARNS COMPANIES
TO STAY ON GUARD FOR POSSIBLE
RUSSIAN CYBERATTACKS RUSSIA MAY
TARGET US BUSINESSES WITH CYBER
ATTACKS- THREAT LOOMS A RUSSIAN
ATTACK ON UNDERSEA CABLES AND
SHUT DOWNS ON ON THE WEST
INTERNET. SO WHAT IN THIS BILL
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT THERE IS
NOT SECURE THAT'S IN THE WERE
NOT WEAKENING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURES BECAUSE WE ARE
WE ARE BEING TARGET TARGETED. SO
IT IS A GRAVE CONCERN OF MINE
THAT WERE NOT ACTUALLY WEAKENING
OUR SYSTEM WE'RE TRYING TO
IMPROVE. VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION
AND THEN IN CYPRUS. IN THE
SECURE OF ALL OF OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEMS I
THINK OUR- FRONT OF EVERYONE'S
MIND. BUT THIS BILL HAS A
PROVISION TO KEEP THE
INFORMATION CONFIDENTIAL. THE C.
P. C. RECEIVES A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT MANY THINGS
INCLUDING THE ELECTRICAL GRID.
INCLUDING ALL OF OUR
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS AND AS AN
AGENCY THEY ARE BASS THEIR VAST
EXPERIENCE. IN MAKING SURE THAT
SENSITIVE INFORMATION IS NOT
RELEASED. THE SAME TIME OUTAGES
HOW MUCH HIGHER LEVEL REPORTED
TO THE SEC THAT REPORTED STILL
TAKES PLACE. IN A TREATED WITH
CONFIDENTIALITY WHEN THEY NEED
TO. THE COMMISSION IS WELL
POSITIONED TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT SOMETHING POSES A
SECURITY RISK AND THAT IS BUILT
INTO THIS BILL. AND THERE
WOULDN'T BE THROUGH A REQUEST OF
THE PUBLIC INFORMATION REQUEST
YOU WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO SECURE
THAT INFORMATION FIFTY THAT THE
COMMISSION TOOK A LOOK AT THIS
INCIDENTS IT WE SHOULDN'T
RELEASE INFORMATION YOU COULDN'T
GET IT THROUGH. THE REQUEST. FOR
IT IF THE VERY BRIEF M. FEMEI
MADAM CHAIR- ON THAT WE DID TAKE
LANGUAGE AS WAS STATED WE
ACTUALLY NEGOTIATED THAT
LANGUAGE BECAUSE OKAY SAY
PUBLICLY WITH EIGHTEEN T. WHO
WAS OPPOSED TO A- SIMILAR BILL
LAST YEAR. TO ENSURE THAT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY INFORMATION-
LANGUAGE WAS NICE AND TIGHT AND-
PIGGYBACKED ON THE EXISTING
PROCEDURES AT AT THE CQC AND SO
THAT WAS SOMETHING WE WORKED
ALSO WITH LET'S COUNCIL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DID IN A WAY. THAT
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE SO IN THE
SAME WAY THAT- ACOSTA JUST
ADDRESS THAT THE CURRENT
PRACTICES ARE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
THOSE WILL APPLY TO THIS BILL AS
WELL. AND DOES THE- UP. HOW AND-
TO ADD ABOUT YOU KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT THIS WOULD PUT US INTO- IT
WE CAN- CREATE A SECURITY THREAT. BUT THE PROOF'S IN THE PUDDING
IT'S THIS IS A PUBLIC REPORT
AGAIN SO. YOU'RE GONNA BE DO A
PUBLIC REPORT BY DISASTER BY
IMPACTS OVER AT THE C. THE
SPONSOR SAY NO IT'S NOT A IT'S
NOT TO BE BY A MEANS THAT THE
BILL IS VERY SPECIFIC ON WHAT
WHAT TYPE OF INFORMATION. TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE SO AND I GUESS
UNTIL WE SEE ONE OF THESE
REPORTS AGAIN. WHY WOULD YOU
WANNA PUT THAT INFORMATION OUT
THERE ABOUT THE IMPACTS- TO OUR
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS. FOR
OTHERS TO LEARN FROM SO THIS
THIS IS ALWAYS BEEN SOMETHING BE
IT THE PC. HAS DISCRETION ON
WHAT IT BELIEVES IT SHOULD BE
PROTECTED. IT'S TO WHAT THEY
BELIEVE AND WE OFTEN DISAGREE
WITH THEM ON THE RELEASE OF
CERTAIN INFORMATION TODAY. SO
BUT IT'S AT LEAST IT'S A VENUE
FOR EXPRESSING OUR CONCERNS BUT
ULTIMATELY IN THE END THE PEACE
YOU MAKE THAT DECISION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. THANK YOU SO IS
THERE- MAYBE WITH- DON'T HAVE
THE AMENDMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE BUT IT'S STATES HERE
THE BILL WHAT AUTHORIZES THE
COMMISSION TO MAKE THAT
INFORMATION PUBLIC CONSISTENT
WITH THE COMMISSION'S PROCEDURES
SO DOES THAT NOT MEAN THAT IT
WOULD BE PUBLIC. IF IT UP
REMONSTRATING I THINK THE
PROCESS WOULD BE KIND OF BOILED
DOWN IS THE INFORMATION BE
PROVIDED TO THE COMMISSION AND
IT WOULD BE MADE PUBLIC PURSUANT
TO THE DETERMINATION OF THE CPC
SO THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THEIR PROCESS DETERMINE WHAT
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO BE- WITH
HELP FROM THE PUBLIC OKAY SO
THERE IS NOT A CONFIDENTIALITY
CLAUSE THAT WAS NEGOTIATED. YET
AGAIN I'M SORRY MANAGER IF YOU
COULD. OKAY I GUESS OF MAYBE I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THERE WAS
LANGUAGE THAT WAS NEGOTIATED
WITH EIGHTEEN T. LAST YEAR WE
MADE SURE TO PUT IT IN THIS YEAR
WE HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS THIS
YEAR TO ENSURE THAT THE CPC'S
PROCESS TO DETERMINE WHETHER NOT
INFORMATION SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
BE MADE PUBLIC OR KEPT FROM THE
PUBLIC THAT THAT WOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL SOME
PERMISSION FIRST GO TO THE
COMMISSION. WOULD NOT BE MADE
PUBLIC UNTIL THE CQC REVIEWED
THE INFORMATION AND DETERMINE
WHETHER SOME OF IT SHOULD BE
WITHHELD FROM THE PUBLIC SO THAT
DETERMINATION THAT FILTER WILL
TAKE PLACE BEFORE ANY
INFORMATION IS MADE PUBLIC OKAY
THAT'S A CONFIDENTIALITY.
ANYBODY ON THE SIDE MEMBERS ANY
OTHER MEMBERS. JUST A QUICK NOTE
SO JUST TO MAKE IT I KNOW WE'VE
GONE THROUGH THIS BUT THAT'S
PROBABLY BY CONCERN IS THAT-
THIS WOULD GO AT ULTIMATELY IT
COULD GO OUT TO THE PUBLIC SO IT
WOULD BE OPEN IN THE AIR THERE
AFTER YOU KNOW GOES FIRST
RESPONDERS AND IT GOES TO
LEGISLATORS BUT IT IS THERE
POSSIBILITY IT'S REALLY JUST
DETERMINES PEACE CAN YOU SEE
DECIDES THEY WANT TO PUT IT OUT
THERE TO THE PUBLIC CORRECT. THE
VERY SPECIFIC- REQUIREMENTS OF
THE COMMISSION HAS TO FOLLOW
PERCENT TO STATUTE- IS IT AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER THE SAME THE
SAME TYPE OF CONFIDENTIALITY
ASSESSMENT THAT WOULD BE
DETERMINED AND RISK PUBLIC
SAFETY RISK THAT IS USED TO
DETERMINE ELECTRICAL GRID AND
OTHER THINGS RIGHT NOW THAT THE
COMMISSION USER BE THAT SAME
PROCESS THAT WOULD BE USED SO WE
FEEL FAIRLY CONFIDENT THAT
BECAUSE THOSE THINGS KIND OF
WORK NOW THE FOR THIS CRAP KIND
OF INFORMATION THAT WE THINK
IT'LL BE EFFECTIVE. THANK YOU.
OUR WE HAD A MO. AND A SECOND.
I'M GONNA ASK YOU HAVE ANY-
CLOSING REMARKS BUT IF YOU WANT
TO ADDRESS A FEW OF THE READ THE
REMARKS I WILL JUST SAY. ALL OF
OUR PUBLIC INFORMATION HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BE. OUT IN THE
PUBLIC EVEN CONFIDENTIAL REPORTS
WE SEE THAT ALL THE TIME. BUT
THE BIGGER QUESTION IS DOES THAT
MEAN WE DON'T MOVE FORWARD ON
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT-
PARTICULARLY IN THESE AREAS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN DISASTER AFTER
DISASTER. I MEAN WE ARE NOT-
WHETHER THERE'S A THREAT FROM
RUSSIA WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE CLIMATE ISSUES SO WE
HAVE TO DO THE BEST WE CAN. WITH
THE INFORMATION WE HAVE. TO
PROTECT ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS
HEALTH SYSTEMS BROADBAND.
EVERYTHING WE HAVE A LOT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO- MOVE FORWARD SO WITH
THAT WE HAD A- MOTION I DON'T.
REMEMBER IF WE HAD A SECOND. A
SECOND. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
CLOSING REMARKS I SIMPLY US FOR
I WROTE. ALL RIGHT WE WILL TAKE
THE TWO. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT QUIRK-SILVA
HI QUIRK-SILVA HI. PATTERSON
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I MEA BONTA HI YEAH BONTA I SAID
I WANT THIS SAID ABOUT THIS HI
DAVIES DAVEY SMELL EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI LO LO I MENTION
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I FELT BY
ANTARA'S RADARS KNOW DOCTOR
WEBER. THE WEBER I. ON THE BILL
WE WILL LEAVE ON CALL BUT WE DO
WANT TO GO BACK AND- TAKE THE
ROLE ON OTHER VOTES. WE WILL
LEAVE THAT THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THEM. RIGHT ON CALL WE HAD. FOR
SOME OF YOU WERE NOT HERE WE HAD
OUR FIRST BILL WHICH WAS AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT OUR CAL ON
GO AHEAD AND TAKE A ROLL CALL ON
THAT. WE HEARD THAT WITHOUT.
BEING IN COMMITTEE SO DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. A MOTION AND A SECOND. MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DAVIES AND SET AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT QUIRK-SILVA
HI QUIRK-SILVA HI PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
HI YEAH BONTA I MEA BONTA I SAID
ABOUT THIS SAID ABOUT THIS I.
DAVIES DAVIES I EDUARDO GARCIA
THE OF THE REST YEAH HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI LO LO MEIN MAIENSCHEIN
MANAGEMENT HI RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ HI MY OF THAT IS THAT
IS I DR WEBBER- WEBER I. WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL
ON CONSENT. BOERNER HORVATH
THESE ARE FOR THE CONSENT AB
TWENTY SIXTY SIX SAID AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SIX BOERNER HORVATH I
EDUARDO GARCIA NONETHELESS YEAH
HI HOLDEN HOLDEN HI LO LO I
MEANT MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. THAT BILL IS THE THOSE CONSENT
ITEMS ARE OUT AND THEN WE WILL
GO BACK TO. CALL ON. AB. TWO SIX
THREE FIVE. THIS IS FOR AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE
BOERNER HORVATH. LEVINE. MY
BOERNER HORVATH I HOLDEN HOLDEN
I LO LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. THAT THE BILL HAS
NINE THREE VOTES. PRESIDENT OF
THE THREE OKAY. MY. BUT WE WILL
LEAVE THE OF ROLL CALL OPEN FOR
ANY MISSED VOTES RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE THE VICE YOU'RE COMING BACK
. OKAY. YEAH YEAH ALL OF THEM
ADDED ON. OKAY HELLO GOOD. THE
COFFEE SPENT. I DON'T THINK. I
ONE TWENTY NINE TO PROVIDE.
RESPOND EXCEPTIONALLY AND A LOT
. ABOUT HISTORY RIGHT. TO
ACTUALLY TO IMPLEMENT AND I'VE
GOT ONE HERE YEAH. THIS. SMELLS
LIKE STERN SO IS SIXTY NINE WITH
ONE OF. HOW LONG DID YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER.
THE MOTION. IN ORDER THE. NINE
ONE. TWO ONE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
ONE MORE A. B. NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT OUR CALDERON- WE WILL CALL
pPATTERSON I. THAT'S A GOOD
THING. YEAH YEAH WHAT ABOUT. FOR
I. OFTENTIMES. VOTER. YEAH CHAU
ONLINE. THEY ARE GOING. YOUR IN
ORDER. ON.
RIGHT WITH THE SUIT.
THE REPORTING OUT FOR-
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
ARKANSAS SENT ITEMS WE HAVE
THIRTEEN ZERO AND- THOSE THAT
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT. NEXT WE
HAVE OF. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT AND AT THAT BILL IS OUT
THIRTEEN ZERO GOING TO-
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. NEXT WE
HAVE AB TWO TWO FIVE TWO WHICH
WILL BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT THAT IS OUT TEN THREE. OUR NEXT WE HAVE AB TWO SIX
THREE FIVE- THIS WILL BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AND THAT IS. OUT
OF NINE. I IS WITH THREE KNOWS.
AND THAT'S A WRAP.